Today is day 17. Let's seek the Lord together for
His holiness in our lives. Just a quick word of exhortation
as we're getting ready to pray. Today, I'm praying with
you, driving down the road on the way to see somebody in the hospital.
Let me just tell you that there's nothing about ordinary life that
is incompatible with seeking God's holiness in our lives.
You can pray and seek Him wherever you are, whatever you're
doing, and I would encourage you to seek Him continually.
Let's pray together.
Father, I rejoice in the holiness that you have provided for
us, that you've gifted to us.
And now, Lord, your Word tells us in Zechariah 14 that
someday,
everything in the universe will be holy to the
Lord.
It's not that way now, Lord, and our heart hurts when we look around and see
so much that is not what it ought to be.
But, O God,
we turn our hearts and ourselves and our minds and our
wills and emotion, everything about us, we turn toward the
task of seeking your holiness in today's
world. We ask, Lord, that you would make
your holiness the cry of our heart now,
and we yield and surrender and ask that you would erase the
line between holy and common in our lives so that
everything is like you. Everything is holy.
Oh, let us be found worthy to come to that
time in the universe where everything is like Jesus, where every
person is like Him, and everything is owned by Him, and everything
is for His honor and His glory.
Make us that way now so that we can be found worthy of coming to
that time. We pray in Jesus' name.
Let's continue seeking the Lord together.